l'audience a débuté par le long compte
rendu du médecin légiste
un monologue qui résume un déferlement
de violence christiane lombard n'a eu
aucune chance
le président du tribunal s'est intéressé
aux armes utilisées l'accusé jean gay 76
ans a confirmé être l'auteur des faits
pour la partie civile l'assassinât ne
fait aucun doute mais les raisons du
geste de moeurs a expliqué la discussion
qui va se développer ultérieurement
cette voie
quelles sont les motivations de l'accusé
est ce que c'est l'amour déçu le crime
passionnel ou est-ce que c'est pas
malheureusement plus terrible que ça
c'est à dire un homme me semble-t-il qui
n'accepte pas la frustration de ne pas
obtenir tout ce qui veut d'une femme et
qui se maîtrise plus à ce moment-là la
relation entre la victime et l'accusé
était complexe selon ses avocats c'est
un homme qui aurait été dépouillés
financièrement par la victime et pousser
à bout
il serait passé à l'acte l'accusé ne
possède aucun antécédent judiciaire
la préméditation de son geste est au
coeur du débat un homme qui est un
citoyen lambda qui n'a jamais été
condamné
qui a fait la guerre d'algérie qui a été
marié qui a travaillé des retraités un
français tout à fait ordinaire qui à un
moment donné de son existence est bien
verrouillé il ya une soupape de sécurité
que nous avons tous en nous qu'ils
étaient fragilisés par cet homme qui
était déprimé traité depuis plus de 30
ans pour la dépression des faits sont
acquis sur le plan matériel il y à une
discussion sur la préméditation
effectivement donc c'est extrêmement
technique mêlée c'est factuellement le
dossier est clair l'audience se poursuit
demain avec d'autres auditions de témoin
et surtout de l'expert psychiatre qui
donnera le profil psychologique de
l'accusé un éclairage supplémentaire sur
les motivations de son geste